hello and welcome to this video cool
opponent yeah that's oh that's ESS
erawan so let's see what yes is up to go
ahead to test the Bangko against him
oh yeah sir what are you doing your this
your scores have a pawn brother so why
don't you take the pawn okay
of course it'd be six line is perfectly
viable I think it's just funny that he
does not want a pony hit Benko when he
always emphasizes how much he likes to
take care take pawns and hang on to them
okay yeah ESS by the way I'm having the
Dutch flag he's living at least largest
part of the yeah I think still in the
Netherlands I've played against justice
teams quite a bit over the years in the
Dutch league so seen him quite often in
that competition never played him
unfortunately could have happened but
never worked out so what's going on here
right to be six
yeah okay let's put it him I was
thinking this is an idea I'm just trying
to try to take the hey five pond as
you're though I'm not the more subtle
play ever but it works out quite often
yeah that covers it I can pay a play
route before though let's see if this is
doing something good at the end I can
take what he's got Bishop d2 right
anyway after currently Bishop d2 is not
on I'm on that I'm on that square simply
if I take a five though he can take on
c8 and then play Bishop d2 hmm that
costs material I don't have to though I
can move this bishop for example I could
play it should be seven which does it
take a five
when the bishop looks Viet there I'm
willing to admit that okay and this is
what I expected so I'll take now yeah
now somehow this night sitting in the
middle of my position what what can I do
here this is not bad anyway
but what am i doing if I can get this
bishop around to be five I would be in
good shape but I wonder if I can do that
the Queen it's going to play rook c1
here anyway
the other idea is to just move the pawn
something like that I would also love to
move the Queen away get this bishop
around but I don't have Queen b8 I don't
have simply quinces seven rope c1 no
good move food strange okay it's kind of
a non move but I didn't I didn't find
anything good
uh-huh this is what he wants to do okay
come on then let's dance I'm sacking
this then that was always an option but
it didn't feel like I'm it's not what I
wanted to do it's kind of a last resort
kind of thing time warning 6ff five or
is he taking him
yeah if I take is taking with the b-pawn
which is not nice
I have to pay for doesn't work okay
why is doing a good job here playing
quite quickly
check
rupee three is not so easy to meet check
check
now how can you have made now you did a
good job there black resigns I have to
check this line again I really don't
think it is anything but I keep getting
bad positions so I let's say positions
that are tough to handle
I don't think white is better him I
don't think but I keep getting I have
four have problems still her somehow
[Music]
so this one yeah I'm better yes but why
and how rook g 4r k hm computers
merciless wow wow that's terrible
yeah like this this is a really bad
position for white I'm sitting on that
fantastic square and his knife looks
like a complete dummy Wow I had a
feeling that something was off here but
grouped you for unknown I was just okay
with grabbing this and he six is the
right solution yeah I took took a long
time here and I kind of had the baptists
feeling that this is right but I
couldn't quite bring myself to playing
it because of his weird night and the
bishop now is doing stuff this was what
I were to irritate it me the computer
just takes him okay here I am I can't I
can't take because here I have enough
counter playing probably tough that's
not so easy to see for a human player
especially considering the night is
coming to that good square and see form
but that was probably the key playing a
six year I wanted here really hard to
get the bishop to
b5 if I manage that I'm fine but there
was no way of doing it this move rook c1
I have no move I have to go back you
know he's threatening to eat eggs before
otherwise that would be nice
Queen c7 rook b8 and then kind of
reroute that stuff
I have to go e6 just what it is I didn't
want to but I have to that's interesting
[Music]
no nothing
still this is nothing special for white
quite clearly but he 6 was strong one
was really strong yeah Bishop d7 was
probably better he was making quick
quick moves and a good moves quickly and
always kept the pressure on difficult
for black him yeah wasn't happy to
change but Queen c8 at computer is move
yeah man a pawn cannot do all that much
okay okay yeah maybe I had chances I
don't know hardly everybody can play
perfectly okay and here I'm already in a
meeting net nothing to do so he 6 e 6
was the thing why do I still have space
for logo in there I replaced that why
very strange anyway our because of the
analysis I see here changed it but not
in the lenses it's okay guys thanks for
watching